- A quick warning:
if you are good at
empathising with other people,
this week's guest video may make you feel short
of breath.
Seriously.
With that out of the way,
let me introduce you to Kurtis Baute,
filming from inside his
homemade, airtight biodome.
Kurtis, good luck.
- [takes breath]
Just over eight hours ago,
I sealed myself inside of this cube.
It is 10 feet by 10 feet by 10 feet,
holds roughly 30,000 litres of air.
I'm gonna try to make this
as short and sweet as I can
because with every breath that I take
I am exhaling carbon dioxide,
and it is toxic at high enough levels.
Right now, it's at
6,370 parts per million.
[takes breath]
But to explain what that really means,
I'm gonna have to step back a second.
Okay, I built this airtight,
plant-filled biodome
for a series of videos on my channel
about how we interact
with the air we breathe.
I have a bunch of safety equipment,
including oxygen and
carbon dioxide sensors
and other gases and
backups and blood monitors
and a paramedic onsite.
Do not try this at home.
It is...
Just don't try it at home. [laughing]
I wanna step back 60 years ago
to when carbon dioxide
levels in our atmosphere
were around 300 parts per million.
Modern day, because of industrialization
and burning fossil fuels,
those levels are now around
400 parts per million
in natural landscapes.
And in urban environments,
it's more like 500 parts per million.
But the thing is, we spend
most of our time indoors,
and that's often in
poorly-ventilated spaces
where the carbon dioxide levels
can reach 1,000 parts per million.
And what's important here
is that researchers have gone out
and tested the higher-order
decision-making abilities
of office employees at different
levels of carbon dioxide,
and they found that at
1,000 parts per million,
there is a 15% decrease
in cognitive function.
[takes breath]
That's a big deal because
we spend a lot of our time
in those sorts of environments.
For example, researchers went to schools
in Texas, Idaho, and Washington,
and they found that in over
50% of those classrooms,
the carbon dioxide levels
went above 1,000 parts per million.
In those same studies, they found
that when levels reached 1,400,
there was a 50% decrease
in cognitive function.
And by 2,000,
there are all sorts of
side effects, [laughing]
which I am feeling a lot
of, including nausea,
loss of attention, uh... [laughing]
I have to read, I have to read them.
Some people report headaches, sleepiness,
poor concentration, loss of attention,
in- increased heart rate, and slight nausea.
But still, these levels aren't uncommon.
Carbon dioxide levels in bedrooms and cars
frequently reach 4,000 parts per million,
and those are places that we
spend a lot of our time in.
We used to use carbon dioxide
as an indicator for when air was stale,
but it's actually probably
the most important part
of what makes air stale.
It's 6,500 parts per million
in here right now
and the air feels thick.
It is clouding my brain.
It is making me do way more takes
in this video than I would've hoped.
When we reach 10,000 parts per million,
you're not supposed to
work an eight-hour day
in an environment like that
because it's probably bad
for your long-term health.
You wouldn't want to be riding a motorcycle
with that much carbon dioxide around you, but
[takes breath]
research shows that it's not uncommon
for motorcycle helmets to have
carbon dioxide levels that are that high.
And I cannot imagine being
impaired at this level
and riding a motorcycle,
let alone at 10,000 parts per million.
Still, we have to go up quite a bit.
We have to go all the way up to 30,000
before levels become extremely dangerous
and potentially deadly.
Now, I have some bad news
and I have some good news.
The bad news is that carbon dioxide levels
are going to go up.
They might even reach 695 parts per million
by the end of the century.
And that means that, globally,
we could end up with something like a 10%
or a 16% decrease in our
cognitive function as a species,
and that's a big deal. [takes breath]
The good news is that we
have the ability right now
to change the environments
that we live in,
both in terms of the overall climate
and in terms of the stale
air spaces that we inhabit.
[takes breath]
So, you can go out and open
a window in your office.
I don't have that luxury, but you can.
You can get some plants in your house.
You can make sure that your HVAC,
your air ventilation systems
are up-to-date and functioning,
[takes breath]
and then you can use
that cognitive surplus,
you can use that bonus to
your thinking abilities
to try and find solutions
for climate change
and how you can make a difference.
Tom, thank you so much for having me.
I'm gonna lie down and stop talking.
- Thank you, Kurtis!
Go subscribe to his channel.
You can start with his series
from inside his biodome
or, if that is a bit much right now,
I also recommend his one-take video
on the entire history of the universe.
Next week is the final guest video,
and it's all about neuroscience.